what else do i want to know about origin
yeah
um
oh there's just so many things it's hard
to think of one i can hear yeah so many
good things to pick from well like what
are origins motives like why is he doing
what he's doing
i don't know
okay well what is he doing
i don't know how do you not know that
you voiced him
it doesn't make sense make it make sense
bestie
what do you mean
how do you not know
what he's doing
because i don't give a [ __ ] i was
there for the paycheck
okay
i have a good question from from chat
here it says uh did epic give rahul the
skin for the person he voiced or does he
have to grind slash pay to unlock it
like everybody else
i have to grind slash pay to unlock it
yeah he does not have everybody else you
want to see this remote bruce are you
ready i bought this to surprise you a
lot with okay
hit it am i nuts well i wanted lana to
see it
hang on okay i'll look i'll look yeah go
ahead
ready yeah
from
2017 or some [ __ ]
that's what you needed me to see
wow
i'm gonna do it all the time
all right let's do it let's go i hate
that fortnite makes it look like kratos
is wearing eyeliner and has like very
manicured brows
yes what's wrong with manicured brows
look how manicured they are
he has better brows than i do
you're trying to keep zach alfinakis in
that tv show he's in baskets
anybody
i mean yeah i've never seen it but yes
yes i know what you're talking about
we're gonna get a win right off at the
very beginning yeah are we okay how to
pull up the map
um
he's like here ish let's do the bugle
again that had some stuff i think that's
where rahul is
holes down here
let's go i'm pretty sure i did that
right
rahul we're going to meet you
oh all right i'm going to meet your
character i think so
dropping boys
yeah
what's that thing that's charging up
i don't know
i know what that is yeah the shield
i was trying to figure that out too john
i have no i have no idea oh hmm
you know i find you origin
space
whoa what do you know
because it wouldn't just be a field
because i think i saw a cliff of someone
near a base like this
all right
hello
is the origin home
the section oh i got a peg i got a keg
everyone hit the grass at the bottom of
this area has anybody
i don't know what he just asked me to do
he just wants to stand here oh
roger that yeah yeah thank you
so he doesn't get shield
what a loser
okay let me make sure there's somebody
here looks correct on the map shoot them
john they're just a bot
it does okay i think it's actually over
this hill but they are just bots they're
just ignoring it so i think it's oh no
that's wrong
i think it's like
so like here
you feel me
yeah well we could walk there yeah we
got to do it quick so we can come back i
still don't have a weapon um yeah
there's one man in that corner there a
lot of london
thank you mate thank you mate
i'm i'm doing so well
you can kill people
wait a minute i think i found him oh no
this is the foundation this is the rock
my sprint okay well that probably means
we're vaguely in the right area because
rahul loves the rock
that's the rock now
oh cool
uh someone's there
stop stop stop correct
oh you're right
oh wow this has like a lot of
like kick to it that i didn't expect
and then we and then we shake them don't
we i can't i'm carrying somebody
everybody
by accident
okay
that sucks i didn't mean to do that
um well you can carry someone who's down
i didn't mean to
that's awesome here shooting
hello origen i'm your number one fan
i think there's a fortnite oh yeah john
do you need help
maybe here uh
never mind it's a room
i think it's him
oh wait i've got a message from origin i
found him
he's here no you didn't yeah i'm coming
i'm coming
he didn't care what he said he didn't
say anything
the text above him says i suggest you
try to impress me but if he said words i
did not hear them
he definitely speaks he wants me to buy
a nighthawk but i don't have any money
oh that's it does he he does definitely
speak i didn't hear him say anything
well we know that he speaks
right no they just paid rahul for
nothing
origin get over here say something
you you punk
buy [ __ ] from him
oh he has
chug origin
are you shooting me
bro
well no dude wait what it's the rahul
wars
oh my gosh you killed russell i've been
gunning style and he shot me
he's not tolerant of that kind of
garbage you should have known
yeah come on man
what what was that about
then like i said i shot him with a tank
you know what
we're going to do this yeah you start
seems cool
i did
hey rubble
always had to happen eventually how does
it feel raul coley talking to him live
right now how does it feel to be the
number one rahul
oh i hate you i hate you so much okay
let's go in the ring
thanks bruce i feel like you have my
back
with those bullets thank you
i'll keep you safe i'll keep an eye out
for danger he didn't say [ __ ] rahul
he didn't say a word
yeah i don't know why sorry i apologize
it's all good is it because i'm is it
because i'm a woman that i just sounded
slightly louder yeah you're like oh what
is this
it was loud it said it was a
high-pitched voice
no it wasn't it wasn't that that gave it
away
painfully unfunny
that's the giveaway i'll talk to you
guys later i'm just playing silence
first in the game it's fine i'll talk to
my chat
i think we'll have ravel's getting
cancelled right now on twitter it's
happening well what's new i don't even
care anymore
nice oh you jump off the
i'm from the lily pads
really yeah
[Applause]
i still maintain that there is too much
game in this video game this video game
has too much game in it it needs to calm
down and leave some game for the other
games
i'm sorry with you there's too much game
there's so much game
you see i dropped a tent look at there
you dropped a tent what
it's a green robot
oh my god alana
i did it on the hopes that he would
shoot at john and he did not
we killed the
brainiac how dare you did we
that's what it said look at my cool
pickup truck you guys i'm on the way to
get chicks
how could they say no let's do this
let's get chicks
maybe this way
why have you left without us you
absolutely we don't want you to hold us
back
i'll start shooting up the car and you
won't know
what
you trailed up at the end there i think
you might have a good trail off yeah
what happened
i tried off intentionally
sure as as one does
okay well i don't see any other hole
yeah i'm not seeing any chicks
we say until we come across a tank
yeah serious
i just feel so directionless where
should we be going oh mark i'm working
like the center
the center that blue yes
oh the pink i could just stay in the
circle maybe i don't know yeah okay we
can head over here
oh damn john you just
popped out the window
you did that like a little like a
it's gonna say like a raccoon but i feel
like what i'm looking for is more um a
meerkat
you ever see a meerkat like sort of pop
out of a hole
uh-huh or gopher that's what you did
that was my favorite animal for years
great animal
we had this this tv show in australia
that's like it was like meerkat manor i
think or something like that
meerkat madness uh it was the prequel to
blind manor and it was actually just
about how these different meerkats like
live their lives and their relationships
and some of them were dead so far away
from
all right we're trying to get chicks
priorities let's go let's go rahul it's
me and you we're gonna we shouldn't we
shouldn't split up
oh that oh there are a lot should we go
shoot him john
where are we going those are npcs i just
dropped my gun but they're all shooting
at one person um i see someone
i feel like we should maybe just go to
brawl and bruh yeah we should go back to
him hey we found like loads of chicks
over here but like we decided we're not
in the mood so we're on our way back but
they all wanted us though they were all
like oh you guys come hang out later
yeah they begged us not to leave yeah we
were like sorry babe
well i got one but that was the bottom
we have friends in need john why aren't
they listening to us
i don't know because we're in the middle
of fighting we are actually fighting
he's right oh really we're coming
through
we're on our way back
wow these guys not properly
communicating at all they would not get
chicks no not not a chance i think we
just got shot at
it's fine and we're low on
hey let's go let's go this way let's go
back toward this
physics on these vehicles okay bruce is
down here should we just jump out are
you guys still fighting or no we killed
him um okay there are dudes this way hey
bruce
i'm here oh
look at that so you want to get in my
car i picked up another chick she's in
the car i'm done
i'm out
so uh where are we going i really like
your truck i uh i mean you clearly have
a big dick
exactly
really yes
which many women have touched
with great frequency we're out a few
reasons yeah what happened to him let's
fight in i have more fuel i have more
filter uh let's see oh do you or i do
yeah sick ah [ __ ]
what should we need help maybe go back
and get them again i just spray it on
the car wow it really looks like you're
peeing on it i'm literally just shooting
it coming on the car
well
i think you maybe need to go to a doctor
but i'm into it
there we go oh wait oh no i'm in your
truck i don't want to drive you pick me
up i'm the god of war how dare you put
me down
okay
oh rahul's here okay john he's still
there um what do you want i
i don't really know
i would like to we're in the circle
fight somebody at some point i think
maybe get better that's not what these
games are about these games are about
anything else fishing
marvel and jumping on
jumping on lily pads
the lily pads are super fun
yes
okay we're doing it we're doing it we're
fine this is a this is a big win here
somebody in chat asks what kind of
research did rahul do to prep for his
role as the origin
well that's a great question
that's i um
[Music]
what did i do yeah when uh so you know
the script yeah
i read it
line by line on the day
uh-huh while recording that's great
yeah so you recorded it it sounds like
you just recorded it
but i had to read the script
but you recorded it
right so yeah so how reading it how much
prep did you do well that that that's
prep that i was prepping to read the
line none of the readers were saying
them yeah you just read it just seconds
before i'd say it yeah i'd read it
that's professional is what that is he's
efficient
you just you just did it you didn't prep
it you did it
well no i had to you know
you probably said are you an editor
no i'm not
you know when you like taken a breath
lick your lips maybe a sip of water
that's prep you do the thing that actors
do where they like straighten their
eyebrows out for some reason
yeah
sounds like you're coming up on some
action some of that there's a lot
i'm ready you think there are girls down
here
i know they're a girl should we engage
i shot somebody those are probably
actual people i want to say
if he wasn't down i don't know how those
are those are real people for sure yeah
i think so too
maybe i've got one
i got one downed
who is this orange fella that's what i
want to know
i think that's a real person not enough
ammo oh god i hadn't even thought about
ammo
oh no well shotgun time i guess
yeah i have not been picking up ammo
was it the orange no i'm not i'm dead
there we go not my bruce
they were really close you might be able
to
yeah calm down okay
okay well i don't have enough ammo to do
a lot about any of this
you guys want to try and revive run into
some ammo yeah yeah yeah we'll try to
hold to me crawl to me i don't know what
i'm picking up okay i have a [ __ ] ton of
ammo now i got you
there's a guy right there down
yeah shut it down oh there's somebody in
that truck
oh [ __ ] i was picking you up that i
shouldn't be doing this right now bruce
i can't
uh john need help need help john i'm
reviving rahul this is a bit more of a
priority though okay well
or is it though okay
i got overwhelmed they were in my face
the patch family eliminated me with a
rifle
where'd they go in the car
okay so you can revive both of us if you
go to that truck oh
and maybe also me
yeah that's what i'm saying both of both
of us
it should bring us both back
okay i'm rebooting there were so many
girls here too so i know
what a shame
is it you that by looking at john
probably you have a lot of ass
that i do a lot of ass
you i don't think did you pick up my
reboot card because
it's there oh do i need to pick up your
reboot yep
it says it's recharging yep oh i rested
bruce i rose okay so you gotta bring a
little bat
from a different one i think
oh you have to wait for this one oh no
it's coming back it's coming back it's
coming recharging
we're still in the circle so
yeah i'm very happy we no longer have
building solaris that's the way that i
felt too the building was not my thing
it was not my thing
but i um
i don't know that this game is my thing
anyway but it is like fun to play with
friends for a little bit obviously
what is this yeah i finally got ammo it
didn't it didn't even occur to me that i
was not picking up ammo
but i wasn't
okay let's go to the next zone
i need ammo we killed that then that
wasn't bots no it's people i think
you got gold
dude yeah some people here
wait wait wait wait we want to look
around vehicle my cow catcher yes
there's looks like there's six people
left we got six people i'm gonna move to
the zone six other people yeah
we should get to the zone
it is an interesting map for sure
i feel that way 100 it's like a lot of
discovery
oh
i'm gonna go
refuse to play out of spite because
so now everyone is not even playing
field regarding the building
i think that's bad i think it's time to
see bruce oh oh
oh many cool things
can you see me bruce
i can yes
i'm looking for people but i can't see
them so they're gold or purple
i think it's gold it's gold gold is
better right than purple yeah
and you find me a gold sniper
[Music]
why are we
why is no one in the area
oh i got over here by me
hey i think they know who i am yep
all
right
me i'm rebooting you fiery
oh [ __ ]
there's some pretty good damage but
there you go you gotta help us guys
oh [ __ ] hell never mind there's a
circle
oh you guys gonna come help us i didn't
realize you guys were in a fight until
just oh y'all realize how close you are
to the end of the game
yeah yeah we're dead wow john taking
risks
go for the res jon do not go for the
shoots
thanks guys they're dead who are you
passive-aggressively thinking i was dead
the whole time
why are you getting passive-aggressive
john i don't think this is it
i don't think you're it
no that's fair probably
you the gun could do that
i want to help i want to help
oh you're alive too bruce i did not
realize that
well man i'm getting shocked
just down
smoke
that
oh no
oh john's getting shot by four people oh
no
well there's only six people left my
friends
second
place
i'm gonna donate two dollars to charity
man i was looking uh
oh we hit ten thousand
what and heck when what in heck and who
oh my gosh thank you to anonymous who
donated six hundred dollars and thirty
one cents to get us to the full ten
thousand there's something that's
amazing right now
um i'm cool with it cool with it
pink okay
thanks john
i'm pink
how are you guys
see if you can see my um how i like
skydive
okay hold on where are you i don't
[ __ ] know i see john
that's me
oh [ __ ] we got uh a lot of people going
over here
we're getting the squad snaped
oh we got it's the incredibles
we are actually getting
the more guy from the incredibles
that's a lot of people landing on this
thing yeah there are a lot
okay
okay let's go
well [ __ ] i got the [ __ ] tank so
y'all can [ __ ] off oh you got a tank i'm
going to where's alana there it is
i'm coming with you
whoa
npcs
they are npcs
and they're gonna kill me that's a real
person
okay i'm driving backwards somehow
uh i think i got that
oh my gosh they're doing a lot did you
guys take no damage and i took all
damage i keep driving backwards by
accident
everybody get out my face yeah that's a
real problem
i needed a gun
okay
that's it for the tank
cool
uh i'm down the real people
i think i got him nope not yet i'm out
of ammo so i can't do anything else then
i'm down
i'm healing he's got to be pretty pretty
save all of this
yeah yeah john can you cover me while i
revive
i think the tank exploded they didn't
run out of fuel i think it exploded it
kicked me out
oh
it's bots
well those are all people i think
yeah it's still got few last people that
people we download all the tank on
yeah they
basically took the thank cow i have no
idea
they know i'm here so they're coming up
oh i just got somebody well um
yeah they know i'm here right
i have no ammo ah
found a chest please have something to
say
yes
chill potion quick i'll take that ah
no look
partners are stupid in this game
are npcs
if you can find a repair torch you can
fix the tank okay noted
noted
oh thank you for donating 100
are you don't taking any damage lady
what you talking to me
dude she's spawning clones
sounds hot
i'm getting shot by bruce is shooting a
real person i was shooting an npc who
keeps duplicating yourself okay yeah can
you shoot them try and get i'm dead they
shot me
all right
i'll i'm coming bruce i'm just healing
i'm gonna die
get the clones
did i get all of them john you got him
you safe okay
that was a weird i'm gonna get you
thank you where are you
right i almost killed the mane and then
she spawned two clones again
sounds kind of hot
here take this guys uh you guys will
probably need this
i'll take that order shotgun so uh my
chat's telling me we can still get in
the tank
but it why would we want to look at it
just as like a turret probably in the
middle of a fight
oh eat the fish all right people no we
can still drive it
eat the fish i have a i have a thermal
fish we need to find a repair torch
maybe it gives you thermal on your
scopes oh it i mean how far away or holy
[ __ ] that's red do you chat do you know
where we can find a repair torch so we
can tank it up
we're in zone there was a repair torch
actually in this big base really massive
we can fix
[Music]
how do you mock stuff
i don't know i keep trying to do it like
apex button is it though
he's on ps5
okay i've got i've got it where's the
guy uh at the back
can can someone in chat tell me how to
mark stuff with a ps5 controller jet
black stuff by clicking in the stick or
tapping on that weird uh i will be
making a cubby video a
[Music]
oh my gosh we got full repair on this
thing uh they said left d-pad
try that
all right
and we have a lot of fuel so
all repair let's go oh yeah uh did you
try a left d-pad roll did it work uh
bruce i called dibs on chariot
left leaf yeah check it see if it works
uh where should we go
i don't know we're in zone we could just
find loot
or maybe find gas
or yeah gas and loot i guess it's really
nice
this is a gas station right here isn't
it please stop shooting the gas station
please stop shooting it right please
it'll it will decay
wait but there's no way that we can do
we get gas in here
[ __ ]
that's what i was worried about
it didn't do any damage to the tank
which is cool that is what i was
concerned about i may have done that um
i just thought it'd be like a regular
drive-through you know what i'm saying
i mean
you didn't you did no damage to it the
tank is okay it's far cry you set all
the grass on fire
and tigers start coming out
uh
did either of you find any gas
apparently
i i blew it up and you you apparently
you can actually grab
the nozzles from the that's what i i
think my friends did that last time i
played
wow i didn't know that i'm so sorry
coconut
yeah i was worried about you shooting
them but i also may have like run over
them a bit i don't know who's really
responsible yeah there's a tank
there's a tank coming
yep right there are we ready for tank on
tank warfare and counter intelligence
john you're going to get killed first
and then we have to go revive you get
out of the tank
all right
i was in the tank and my health got
brought down to five so
oh
oh it might not have been a tank it
might have been one place
maybe it's just the board how did you
mistake that
i don't know because it was moving
slowly and it was dark i got scared
rolling rolling rolling
okay
you're gonna try to find more fuel and
more loot is the plan
there's usually a gas can in the garage
yes i do know you can use the gas
station pumps red gas cans randomly in
garages
all right
where are those later
oh oh
also alana i have a i still have that
blowtorch so if you take damage i can
get out and repair you [ __ ] yes
i'm feeling good it's great that we're
telling everyone where we are i want to
fight we are driving towards the
the ring um yeah why why you're right
other direction
no you're obviously yeah i marked uh
oh we're gonna run out of fuel again
ah whatever
boost it baby
all right bones fuel way too fast
said this song never gets old
[Laughter]
truly
thank you krogen quotes
has anybody seen a garage
no okay
but the next gas station i see i'm gonna
blow that one up too please i only
pressed it once
it might loop i guess
yeah i'm just curious how long it looks
for but it's probably going to [ __ ] your
switch up
no no it doesn't i don't hear the song
playing
what
no i have no one tank i have not once
heard the song play there's another tank
right over here keep going keep going
straight oh
new tank
we should go get it
actually we should have two tanks
who wants to drive out of the tank i'm
just about to run out of fuel
well shooting is happening
oh [ __ ] you're right oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
we're being attacked
yes we are
[ __ ] we have two tanks try me
who's your daddy oh there's a tank
there's a gun up there that they want to
shoot at us probably so be careful
i broke it i'm trying to shoot at that
but it doesn't seem doable
that's got to be a bot they're just
standing out in the open
i don't know the bots are that jumpy
that's true
i also hid when i broke his shield
yeah i'm not sure about the boat
situation we are low on fuel again
uh this one is probably not the one that
ravel and i are in
yeah that's true the just i just i loved
the two tank situation we were really
pulling for there
all right i got the guy who's up top
you seen any fuel john
nope
hot dang
[ __ ] this tree
rolls going up to the top
i have the hiking first person went
firing i didn't know that thank you
maybe this will have fuel ah
all right we made it
it doesn't look like a garage but maybe
it'll have fuel there's stuff up here
i don't know i'm gonna get ambushed down
here
what's that you got the high ground okay
where'd he go you're down below
i just saw him
uh they're down there
what is that oh they're dead
whoa
25 players remaining
oh i got a tank coming inbound right
there
i can't see
i can't see him
oh all right bruce
i'm trying to come up the hill you guys
look like you're falling right now oh
yeah we fell oh okay but we got it
we got it i just want fuel
oh great
there we go
the [ __ ] this whole you're telling me
this whole building ain't got no fuel
oh no
are they in there
they've got to be
hey guys i'm gonna leave this tank right
oh
my gosh
oh there's a crate coming down
oh you can aim first person
that's pretty sick
the hell is it great hey guys
i got sodas
i feel like an [ __ ]
this is rude
what are you doing i can't hit this
person uh i'm like sniping with the tank
basically the aiming is awful
uh uh we are uh
we gotta get in jail
i can't
hit you i have seven health and i'm
stuck down below i literally can't hit
him john i'm here we're here we're here
getting bruce see him
they're going for the job watch out
got him
nice oh there's a health set right here
there's two of them down right here
i don't care whatever
another one
another one
that's a bot that's a bot
i don't understand what the tents do i
need health john that's the health get
right there i've already pinged okay
mark why
here we go why um okay i need to get to
you i dropped my best weapon also in a
panic
there's a lot of uh there are a lot of
weapons oh
you're so far down
you just slide down the hill
it seems like okay yeah this is why
everybody's using the tank
john there's all sorts of [ __ ] for you
right there
that's the coolest thing i've ever done
oh you guys i just power slid to you it
was dope
the one's flying
hello copy that uh oh yeah is that a
person
what the [ __ ]
what what the
uh john you're
by yourself john
that's cool
you're by yourself i don't want to cause
people i didn't assume that three trees
what the [ __ ] oh two trees
oh really you want to shoot us
they have more rain we're getting shot
from across the way as well
who's shooting at you
uh i'll ping him in a second hold on
i can't see past this tree
our wheels are gone oh
yeah
i'm like on the wrong side of the tank
so i just can't even see past the tank
oh yeah i know what you mean
um
why are we moving like this i don't know
he's stuck let me let me repair you hold
on in the broken tank and i killed a
dude and i'm killing his friend
hell yes
this thing has dog [ __ ] range
nice bruce
okay you're repaired there's a guy where
i marked there's a guy
who just killed those people who
understood that as a god
was it you did we do that did we kill
them
yeah we got them okay so uh john smith
has got overwatch
man on the floor on the ground on the
ground he's throwing a grenade there's a
dude up up on top of the
blimp or whatever the [ __ ] i was just
running to john's ping which does not
have anything oh my god this is brutal
yo we might we might do this
yeah john's up in there in the in the
circle oh this is great
yeah that's where i popped that's where
i parked that tank when it ran out of
fuel i popped it up there that is
perfect convenient i didn't think it
would last that long
there's only five people left i mean
there's two people left right there's
two there's one person up on the roof up
here
all right i'm gonna try and run to them
on foot
because in theory you'd be distracting
them i have very little health though i
think if i don't boost i can get us up
there bruce all right john which oh i
see them i'm shooting right at him
yeah i see him
peek up you dick can you shoot this
thing down i wonder all right he sees me
nowhere i need your support john uh i'm
down yeah i did not have enough house to
pull that off it's fine i think we'll be
okay
no you don't need to stress about me
really
uh we're gonna get we're gonna get to
you here
i thought about resting but it seemed
like a bad time to do it i don't know if
people could like stop you from resting
so i'm going to jump out for a second
and use my sniper rifle in this car yep
that makes sense
he's the only one left you guys first
boom he's the only one left
there's four of us
yeah somebody should revive alana if we
can i'm coming
i've got full health oh
and then we just [ __ ] go own this
dude
yeah is he not dead yet no
i think i might have knocked him off of
the
oh really
because i hit him with a bomb and he
flew away
yeah you might have done
okay bruce that's huge
yeah i see him i've i got him where is
he where is he he's he's in like right
there right right pink oh like oh under
there
yeah he's under it okay exactly
let's see if i can like in the building
but or like anything but under the thing
yeah i don't know if you can actually
shoot that uh
i just want to get down without dying
okay let's
did try fall through
i'm not seeing him but i have a ring's
closing so
med kit here for anyone needs one
if we all stay in it doesn't he like
have to come up
yeah well i'm just afraid he's gonna
kill all four of us
see
where where where where
uh on me
i didn't see exactly where he was oh
he's in there again he's in there
and he's in the blimp
i just wish i knew where he was
he's just here i'm shooting he's right
there
by the way because i'm
i'm in trouble
rahul rezmi
hold on we need to push him
all right all right all right go get
john go get him bruce
i've missed so many of these shots
is he he's a professional there we go
yeah i just spray and prayed with that
shotgun and i did so badly but we killed
him
we got him we got him we got him and
thanks for our who we all did it
because i would have died
yeah that hey everybody that means you
donate to charity i donated every time
we lost 60 ladies we win
you donated not you one dollar for the
victory right now
thanks thanks john i marked a pink place
oh you're going to pink
always
always go to pink
[Music]
never the stink never this always the
pink
the stink is sinful
oh wait no the pink is simple wait which
one's sinful no
sinful if you're mormon the pink is
sinful
yeah that's true they do butt stuff
because the lord doesn't care exactly
i glide in by the way it was intended
yeah i've got this dope
thing
wow you're you're so far up dude yeah
this looks like left 4 dead 2.
hey it does
yeah kind of does this is where the tank
shows up
[Music]
you okay
yeah is he doing a voice sir
is that what the origin sounds like if
we hurt him it's the fortnight people
just more games
too much video game in the video game
what is this mushroom oh i don't mind if
i do it's a fireplace
firefighter it's like a little fire bomb
oh
those are really great
really really great yeah they're they're
they're like really good all it's always
a good good way to put it yes
and ten thousands
oh there's a person here [ __ ] you would
not believe your eyes all right oh
what is going on
fair i just killed the i can just kill
the floss the floss patrol please take
me away from here i just killed the
pumpkin knight
the pumpkin pattern where are they
coming from is that the onion knights
cousin
i don't know
[ __ ] who you think you are
those are bots for sure yeah
you're right
uh there's a sniper rifle here if
anybody wants it i want it
it's a chug splash
uh chuck splash is like you throw it and
it's like a shield
um
again
again that's gotta
might not be anyone know what med missed
but i'm being honest yeah medmess is
actually a really good heel oh hey how
dare you slightly strafe backwards and
forwards and actually dupe me
what
there you go [ __ ] hell
anonymous 335
way to go i'm not happy with my loadout
right now
no no one is i need more ammo real bad
i hear him
i tried to yoink that from you rojo i
saw i gotta take me away from here
i got another repair torch gonna keep it
just in case yeah we're gonna place
these i believe in us we're going to
find a tanker too
i jumped in a dumpster fire flies
why do you keep telling me when birds
are nearby i don't give a [ __ ] who are
you odin
so you shoot uh if you shoot the players
they give you they give you purple
weapons oh oh i oh i do care oops
i actually super care about that
the purple birds
uh-huh why do we swim like dolphins in
this game
i really
we asked for clarification you just said
the purple birds
what about them no no everybody said
yeah if you shoot the purple birds they
drop purple weapons oh they drop purple
weapons okay does anybody have a i got
some machine submachine gun
combat smg
i'm across the river by the way
in the houses
yeah we see it we see here we see here
johnny smith do you have any sub machine
gun anymore that i could use
uh let me check
and i have some sniper rifleman for you
oh hell yeah i could use shotgun ammo
medium bullets
i've got that as well here you go or
light bullets what are you doing the
little guys the littlest ones
this looks like a great place to start
man
i'm trying to go to hawaii at some point
this year
oh yeah i just it's been so long since i
swam in an ocean i would just really
like to do that
it's beautifully oppressed yeah
you realize you live in a place that has
an ocean yeah and it's
it's [ __ ] nasty and cold san diego
what if i went to hawaii
that also works hawaii is better it's
sandy i don't know how on the beaches
are they i'm not actually yeah and
there's not [ __ ] oil slicks
everywhere
are they warm
yes
sort of
because there's this thing that
americans do where they tell me about
how great certain beaches are and i'm
like uh because i come from the land now
you just gotta go to san diego yeah i'll
beat you diego's actually a great
no no the biggest i mean of course
hawaii is better than san diego
i think australia is overrated yeah you
always say that what the [ __ ] the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ]
oh you did that oh i thought somebody
did that at us and i was like that's the
coolest thing i've ever seen
what was it do you guys like this
rocket
oh we should get in the ring
yeah i'm in the ring right now getting
your ring
hot hey
could not believe my eyes can't damn it
i've been nervous
uh let me see if i can't oh yeah you
know left me in it no bruv hang on wait
rahul you it's not leaving you we're
just heading in the direction of bruce
you lot left me in it oh my god so needy
look at me go i'm a dolphin
oh guys i can't believe they do my boy
kratos like this
yes [ __ ]
yeah swimming is pretty good
works pretty well
you've never seen the ocean in your life
whoa
what was
that jellyfish are not really a concern
in australia though like sure they exist
you hop in this i swam like every
weekend into my entire childhood all
right john did get stung once but mostly
i have a gun
look at my crazy gun oh wow you do have
you guys yeah push me all right hold on
actually can you break it off
i wish
this game's too much man
this can't be happening
the video game is too much no
oh no
come on
oh i'm taking a lot of damage
uh you've never tried to go to the ocean
you should
okay we popping out
yeah
some of the games are so fast and some
of them are so slow man
what a time to be alive
get him get him
get him get him get
he's he's [ __ ] out ammo i very much
need ammo oh my god john that's so sick
there was a fight in here for sure
i got a llama
well maybe not maybe there wasn't a
fight in here
shooting it
like there might have been uh it's it's
a loot llama isn't it
oh i just dropped tons of loot go get it
let me go with the auto shotgun
the ranger assault rifle i don't know
which which rifle i like the most i
think i'm gonna put combat smg i don't
know
i just like don't even know
all right we gotta go to the uh
go to the circle
let's go to the side we gotta go
thank you anthony dennis thanks for
joining me
this is the 13th month it's my 12-month
anniversary i mean i'm actually further
behind than you
yeah but you can go faster than me
are you still in
the speedboat maybe you have a problem
this doesn't feel safe oh [ __ ] you can
boost
uh there's a fight over there but it
looks like maybe ai it could there's
probably a person i was asked who's
doing the exclamation marks that's me
that's me oh okay i'm telling you where
the fight is yeah
um
so we should probably steer clear of it
honestly
yeah we none of us got full shields
right now which is not my fave oh you
also don't don't have a tank did you say
fave yeah it's like not my favorite
oh here i've got something for us come
come to where i am come come here
is he coming is it chug jug party
it is chug chug party
finally
come on over for the challenge uh you
guys i have ptsd this is where we died
this is where we die this is the trees
one tree
we'll be fine
[Laughter]
oh my god i'm telling you
the greatest part
maybe the greatest video game we've ever
that's ever been made it's just the most
video game of all video games yeah it's
not the greatest it's just the most
never has there been a more video game
[Laughter]
all right are we are we good should we
roll out
nope okay
no
oh my gosh it's going again
oh there's a blowtorch here does
somebody already have a blowtorch i do
have a blowtorch yeah yeah
this is a four-door
is it i'm hopping in
all right
let's go get chicks in a honda civic
we're gonna this is gonna get exploded
immediately it's it's more like a toyota
corolla i apologize to the honda civic
community
it does not have a boost
also it maxes out at 32 miles per hour
just use it to find us a tank
and it's low on fuel and you hit a tree
there we go all right well
that was a good ride hey it was a great
ride thanks john really meant a lot to
me i had a great time john
thanks for your contribution
contribution to the team
ah there we go
i got stuck in the animation for the
like dolphin jump and then kicked me off
of the the the
lily pad while i was
oh yeah i know you're talking about dumb
[ __ ] guys i have three full heals up
saying that word i'm trying to get it
out of my vocab
i keep saying dumb i'm trying to not say
dumb
i'm gonna replace it why
um
it's stable it's it's not a good type it
used to mean mute right
you shouldn't say dumb well i didn't say
you i'm just trying to get it out of my
pocket i'm not trying to tell anybody
else what to do yeah no no not your
rules yeah you ain't got to do [ __ ] i
really don't
oh my god
it's a great fun time playing fortnite
with you ronaldinho
someone was having a go at someone on my
twitter feed because they said did you
fan girl over mark hamill and um
this person is having a go at them for
being misogynistic and misgendering me
wow
that's too much that's fine you could
just
ignore it if you don't there's a there's
clearly a fight over here
yep there it is
there's a fire
i don't know i'm making another one oh
okay wow there's trees glowing oh my god
it's eldon ring
the lands between
wow
yeah be careful they are clearly clearly
lit
let's take the zone let's take the zone
back up run back from back back in the
zone
uh i got hit
i'm also being hit
i gotta get rahul oh he got hit bad hit
oh
real real
ow
they grapple hooks me back to the group
i am gonna die yeah
yeah
john where are you
don't worry about it i can only do so
much
don't worry about it
that's me gone
all right i got stressed there were too
many of them i got stressed
okay
don't
oh bruce is back i thought you were gone
too
nope oh i'm still alive
yeah i know i'm not trying trying to
smoke these fools
all right let's do it oh
i literally got you right as you [ __ ]
man all right well grab his card grab
his card i got his card i got his card
oh man sorry dude
no no i died ages ago dude oh you did oh
yeah
no
i think someone else who was down
probably just expired oh
honestly we should probably wait here
because i bet they're going to come back
for their buddy
is everybody here sure yeah yeah yeah
bruce is right they're ready to shoot
their
all right circle's closing shackle is
closing my gosh here they come oh here
they come
on
where are they down in kind of like the
swamp area
but they're gonna try and get their
buddy so let's just if we just stay by
uh say here they're gonna
is there somebody down there
that is right there there he is
man uh armor broken i think on that guy
yeah john's about to flank him
damn it oh my gosh come on bro his armor
was not broken but it is now it is lit
up never mind
yeah he jugged it all right
guys nice job
nice work lads all right so we gotta we
got a rez rahul
yeah don't worry about me it's not a
priority get like
three of you right now
you're going to be getting shot from all
angles there's 12 people left yeah yeah
spicy
so there's eight
so there's two more teams so don't worry
about me
all right wait for their friends wait
for their friends nice
copy
there's a tank oh [ __ ] there's a tank we
got caught we should probably go [ __ ]
tank
yeah
we should go zone
[ __ ] man let's go zone let's go down
this way
isn't the tank going zone
well yeah
we've all got to that reboot van's right
there
is it oh wait wait where the tank is
right there um the tank is right there
yeah running
yeah run run away from it okay yeah
don't worry about the reboot you can't
find it it's actually
i thought it was either there might be
another one closer to the side oh he's
picking up his friend's uh tag yep i
[ __ ] knew it
how much we can do about a tank also i
have no health so if we do get in a rush
here i'm just [ __ ] useless here elana
i've got this for you guys i have missed
let me use it yeah the miss is really
good it's really funny to watch kratos
spraying his own face oh damn that's so
quick origin's there he might help help
you oh he will help me
what do you think origen oh okay being
shot in the back guys being shot in the
back all right we're coming quick real
quick lana's down
is that origin nice very nice nice
bruise
he did it with an origin skin yeah
no i'll be fine
don't let me just crawling away just
crawling away
it's always the [ __ ] tank whoever has
the tank wins the match
there i go
christy off got me
bruce walk over here walk over to me
you got it
they don't know i don't think oh does he
know
oh no
i don't
think they do
we're repairing here we just wait here i
don't move at all [ __ ] they're repairing
we gotta shoot them oh ring wait the
ring's closing on you
they don't know they don't know you guys
they do not know
don't get seen don't get seen yeah i'm
healing up
you take my [ __ ] it's fine holy [ __ ]
john you're like full health bro
hell yeah i am you look like ninja when
you're playing you're moving so quick
like
inventory
four people left you guys that's 2v2
but they have a tank
we've got to smoke this tank we gotta
shoot it right now
all right what do you have grenades
anything i don't have any grenades no
there's one yeah they're off the tank
they're the tank yeah
i think the tank guy might be alone
right now
this is such a good position you're good
you're good
there's just one more
[Music]
you're waking the [ __ ] out of them
johnny
what a final game